Transcriber: Tutku Tunalı
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Felsefe ne işe yarar?
Hayatımın sorusu.
O yüzden gelin sizinle de
bugün bu soruyu tartışalım.
Mesela birkaç fikir atalım ortaya.
Ne işe yarar felsefe?
Felsefe her şeyi
didiklemeyi seven merakıyla,
sinir bozmaya yarar diyebiliriz.
Mesela filozoflardan
yaptığınız alıntılarla
sosyal ortamlarda havalı görünmeye yarar
ama en çok da aslında
rakı sofralarında işe yarar.
Böyle muhabbet uzar gider, masadan biri
"Amma felsefe yaptınız!" diyene kadar
çıkmazların içinde keyifleniriz.
Şaka bir yana,
gerçekten ne işe yarar felsefe?
Felsefe okuyorum, felsefe öğretiyorum,
felsefe doktorası yapıyorum dediğim zaman
istisnasız karşılaştığım soru hep bu oldu.
"Ne işe yarar felsefe?"
Neredeyse 20 yıldır çeşitli ortamlarda,
çeşitli insanlar tarafından
bu soru soruldu bana.
Kimisi gerçekten samimi
bir merakla soruyordu,
kimisi bazen biraz alaycı,
kimisi de geleceğim için kaygılandığı
için soruyordu galiba bu soruyu
ve ben her seferinde ciddiye alıp,
her seferinde bir
cevap vermeye çalışıyordum
ve bir zamandan sonra şunu fark ettim:
Ben bu işi yapmaya devam ettikçe
bu soru benim peşimi bırakmayacak.
Bırakmasın da
çünkü ben de onun peşini bırakmayacağım.
İşte bugün, size anlatmak
istediğim konu da tam bu.
Neden bazı soruların
peşini bırakmamalıyız?
Neden bazı sorularla,
ömür boyu bu bitimsiz kovalamaca
oyununu sürdürmeliyiz?
İddiam şu:
Hayatımıza şekil veren,
hayatımıza tonunu kazandıran şey
aslında cevaplarımız
değil, sorularımızdır.
Cevap arayışı aslında soruyu yaşamamızdır
ve soruyu da, ancak soruyu
bir cevapla dondurup öldürmeden,
soruyu hep açık ve canlı
tutmakla mümkündür.
Şimdi dönüp bakıyorum ve fark ediyorum ki,
yüzlerce defa neredeyse karşılaştığım,
maruz kaldığım bu soru,
"Felsefe ne işe yarar?" sorusu sayesinde
aslında soruları cevaplardan
daha çok sevmeye başlamışım.
Çünkü bu soruya cevap ararken
aslında fark etmişim;
cevaplar uçucu ve sorular kalıcı.
Yıllar geçiyordu
çünkü ben felsefede yeni bir öğrenciydim
ve yavaş yavaş üniversite bitiyordu.
Master'a başlamıştım,
doktoraya başlamıştım,
yeni insanlarla tanışıyordum,
yeni deneyimler ediniyordum
ve hâliyle bu soruya verdiğim
cevaplar hep değişiyordu.
Bazen tutunduğum, sevdiğim,
gurur duyduğum bazı cevaplarım oluyordu,
"Tamam" diyordum,
bu işe yarıyor, gayet güzel
ben de memnunum, üstelik
insanları da ikna edebiliyorum.
Ama bir süre sonra o cevaplar da
dökülmeye, elimde tutamamaya,
yetersiz kalmaya başlıyordu
ve ben tekrar kendimi başlangıç noktasında
soruda buluyordum,
tekrar soruya dönüyordum,
tekrar soruyla bir ilişki kuruyordum
ve bugün fark ediyorum ki,
aslında benim felsefe yapmaya
devam etmemi sağlayan itki
bu soruyla kurduğum ilişki
ve bu kovalamaca oyunuymuş aslında.
Çünkü şunu fark ettim;
aslında bizi geliştiren şey
cevaplarımız değil sorularımız,
soruyu yaşamamız ve soruyu açık tutmamız.
Çünkü soruyu açık tuttuğumuz zaman,
bir cevaba saplanmıyoruz
ve cevap artık işe yaramadığı zaman,
onu kolaylıkla elden çıkarabiliyoruz.
Bu cesaret isteyen bir şey
ve tam da bizi geliştiren şey aslında bu.
Cevaplar işe yaramadığı zaman,
onları bırakabilme cesareti gösterip
tekrar, yeniden soruya geri dönmek.
Peki hepimiz cevap arayışındayken,
ruhumuzu daraltan, sıkıştıran, acı veren
hâllerden kurtulmak için
çareler, cevaplar ararken,
ben niye gelmiş bugün karşınızda
soruları yaşamanın daha önemli
olduğunu anlatıyorum?
Şu yüzden;
çünkü cevap vermek, soruyu öldürmektir.
Cevap vermek soruyu dondurur.
Bir cevapla soruyu
paketlersiniz güzel bir şekilde,
rafa kaldırırsınız, araştırma da biter.
Geriye ne merak kalır
ne de soru kalır.
İşte felsefenin önemi
tam da burada ortaya çıkıyor,
çünkü felsefe bize şunu hatırlatıyor;
hiçbir cevap kesin ve nihai değil.
Her cevabın, cevaplarımızın hepsinin
bir son kullanma tarihi var
ve bu kullanım süresi bitince
aslında biz bir bocalıyoruz
çünkü önceden işimize yarayan,
dünyayla ilişkimizi takır takır
sürdüren bu cevaplar,
hayata anlam vermek için
kullandığımız bu cevaplar,
artık işimize yaramamaya başlıyor
ve tam tersi önümüzde
engel teşkil ediyor.
Harekete geçemiyoruz
çünkü saplanmışız o cevaplara.
İşte bunları bırakmakla özgürleşiyoruz
ve bu cevapların
son kullanma tarihi geldiğinde
bu cevapları bırakabilir
hâle gelmemiz gerekiyor
çünkü öteki türlü
hem kendimizi sıkışık hissediyoruz,
hem bir bocalama içinde kalıyoruz,
hem bir adaptasyonda zorluk yaşıyoruz
ve bu beraberinde
bir boşluk hissi,
bir anlam krizi
ya da hiçbir şeyin çare etmediği
bir mutsuzluğu da getiriyor.
İşte bu noktada
soruya geri dönme vakti.
Soruyu tekrar ele alabilme
cesareti gerekiyor.
Şimdi--
düşünün, bazı sorular vardır;
"Ben kimim?"
"Beni ne mutlu eder?"
"Vücuda getirmek istediğim
değerler neler?"
"Hayatımın anlamı ne?"
İşte bu sorular,
insanlığın bin yıllardır sorduğu
ve yığınla cevap bulmalarına rağmen
hâlâ eskitemedikleri,
hâlâ tüketemedikleri sorulardır.
Bu sorular, öyle paketlenip,
rafa konulacak sorular değildir
çünkü koyduğunuz raflarda
rahat durmazlar.
Hep cızırtı yaparlar,
hep yeniden ziyaret
edilmeyi talep ederler.
Düşünün.
Bu soruları eminim
siz de sormuşsunuzdur kendinize,
kim bilir kaç defa hem de
ve cevaplarınızı düşünün.
20 yaşında verdiğiniz cevaplarla,
daha sonra 35, 55,
kim bilir 85 yaşınızda
bu sorulara vereceğiniz
cevaplar aynı olabilir mi?
İşte bu da bize şunu gösteriyor ki,
hayatımıza rehberlik eden aslında
cevaplarımız değil, sorularımız
çünkü cevaplar geliyor ve geçiyor.
Cevaplar değişiyor
ama sorular hep aynı kalıyor.
Her şey değişse de,
bu sorular aynı kalıyor
çünkü zaten her şeyi
değiştirecek olan şey,
bu soruların ta kendisi.
Az önce de bahsettiğim gibi,
benim hayatımda değişmeden kalan,
sürekli döndüğüm, sürekli ziyaret ettiğim,
hayata o soru üzerinden baktığım soru
"Felsefe ne işe yarar?" sorusu.
Hayatı bir soru ışığında deneyimlemenin,
bir soruyu yaşamanın ne demek olduğunu
"Felsefe ne işe yarar?"
sorusu sayesinde anladım.
Çok yalnız kaldığım, hayatta verdiğim
bütün kararları sorguladığım,
artık hayallerimin bile
beni teselli etmediği
çok mutsuz, umutsuz,
kalbimin kırık olduğu bir dönemde
dönüp baktım,
"Elimde ne var,
bunca sene ne biriktirdim acaba?" diye
ve filozofları buldum
ve onlara sığındım.
Aklımdaki soru yine aynıydı:
"Felsefe ne işe yarar?"
O an içinden geçtiğim sorunlara
bir cevap olabilir mi felsefe?
Beni teselli edebilir mi?
Ve bu süreçte felsefenin iyileştirici
ve özgürleştirici gücünü fark ettim.
Çünkü bütün verili
ve hazır cevaplardan uzaklaşmak,
o belirsizlik alanında kalmak,
aslında beni kendi
sorularımla yüzleştirmişti.
Kendi sorularımı görmüştüm.
Hangi soruları yaşamak
istediğimi fark etmiştim
ve bu oldukça özgürleştirici
bir deneyimdi.
Şimdi bunu daha iyi anlatmak için
gelin sizi felsefe tarihinin
en güzel sayfalarına davet edeyim
ve Platon'un mağara benzetmesine gidelim,
felsefenin iyileştirici gücünü
orada bulmak için.
Dilimize "Devlet" adıyla çevrilen
Platon'un bu çok önemli eserinde
Platon, yer altında karanlık
bir mağara tasvir eder.
Burada bir grup insan vardır ki
bunlar ömürleri boyunca
boyunlarından ve ayaklarından
zincirli bir şekilde,
önlerindeki duvara bakar hâlde otururlar.
Nereden geldiği belli olmayan
birtakım gölgeler yansıyordur bu duvara
ve bu insanların gerçekliği de hâliyle
önlerindeki gölge oyunudur.
Şimdi bu noktada dinleyicilerden biri
şöyle bir şey söyler:
"Aaa! Ne garip bir tasvir bu?
Ne garip insanlar!"
Anlatıcı da:
"Evet, bize benziyorlar," der.
Evet, Platon bu insanların
bize benzediğini söylüyor
çünkü tıpkı onlar gibi biz de
algıladıklarımızı gerçek olarak alıyoruz,
bize söylenenleri,
ailemizden, toplumumuzdan
öğrendiğimiz değerleri, normları,
kitle iletişim araçlarından
akan şeyleri gerçek kabul ediyoruz
ve bu doğrultuda bir
gerçeklik resmi kuruyoruz.
Bu doğrultuda bir dünya
resmi çiziyoruz kendimiz için.
Ve giderek kalıp yargılar oluşturuyoruz,
giderek bunlar kemikleşiyor.
Kendimize ve dünyaya dair
birtakım doğrular ediniyoruz
ve bunların içinde rahat ediyoruz
çünkü bu gölge oyunu
tıkır tıkır akıyor.
Kanıksıyoruz bunu.
Başka bir gerçeklik daha olabileceği
ihtimalini düşünmüyoruz bile.
Bütün bu ön kabuller,
varsayımlar, fikirler
sarsılmayacağını sandığımız doğrular
bize bir konfor alanı sağlıyor
çünkü artık burada soru yok.
Artık burada cevap var.
Hazır cevap var.
Neden soru sorarak kendimi
meşgul edeyim, yorayım ki?
Ve bu hazır cevaplarla,
bu kalıp cevaplarla yaşayıp gidiyoruz
ve hikâye devam ediyor.
Mağara bundan ibaret değil sadece.
Öyle bir an geliyor ki
bu mahkumlardan biri,
bir anda serbest bırakılıyor.
Zincirler kırıldı.
Yıllardır oturan beden,
şimdi ayağa kalkacak ve hareket edecek.
Kullanılmayan kaslar, şimdi uyanacak.
Bunun nasıl bir acı olduğunu düşünün
ve tabii ki, bu kişi ayağa
kalktığında ilk yapacağı şey
dönüp arkasına bakmak olacak
ve arkada gördüğü ateşe
ilk etapta bakamayacak
çünkü karanlığa bakmaya alışkın gözleri,
ateşi gördüğünde kamaşacak
ve yavaş yavaş alıştığında,
gözler ateşin ışığına adapte olduğunda,
fark edecek ki mağarada aslında
başka bir hayat varmış.
Başka bir grup insan daha
yaşıyormuş mağarada.
Üstelik epey de garip insanlar
çünkü birtakım kuklalar
ve heykeller taşıyorlar ellerinde.
Kişi şaşkın.
Bunlar kim?
Bir kuklalara bakıyor,
bir gölgelere bakıyor.
Kafası karışık.
Tabii ki ilk etapta idrak edemiyor
yıllardır gördüğü gölgelerin
kuklaların gölgeleri olduğunu
ve tekrar gölgelere bakıyor,
gölgeler kocaman.
Duvarda kendi kendilerine
süzülür gibi hareket ediyorlar.
Ondan sonra kuklalara bakıyor.
Kuklalar küçük ve üstelik
başkaları tutuyor onları,
kendi kendilerine hareket edemiyorlar.
İyice kafası karıştı.
Tekrar gölgelere bakıyor,
gölgeler karanlık.
Kuklalara bakıyor, kuklalar biraz
daha renkli ve daha detaylı
İyice allak bullak oldu.
Hangisi daha gerçek?
Bu noktada, bu kişinin
kuklaların daha gerçek
olduğu fikrine alışması zor.
Yıllardır getirdiği
birtakım doğruları var,
onları hemen terk edemez.
Ama öte yandan,
bu gerçekliği gördükten sonra
artık gölgelerin gerçek olabileceğine
inanması da zor.
İyice bir yol ayrımında.
Kafası iyice karışık.
Her şey allak bullak.
Bütün, şu ana kadar doğru saydığı
her şey elinden kaymak üzere.
Sen de bu bocalamayı yaşamadın mı?
İnandığın, tutunduğun,
benimsediğin tüm doğrular
yeri geldiğinde bir tiyatro dekoru
gibi üzerine devrilmedi mi?
Tutunduğun hiçbir şey kalmazken,
ortalık yerde yapayalnız
neye inanacağını bilmez
bir hâlde kalakalmadın mı?
İşte zincirlerden özgürleşmenin
ilk etkisi epey ağır.
Ama hikâye burada bitmiyor.
Devam ediyor.
Şimdi artık cevaplardan özgürleşen kişi,
soruyu yaşamaya başlayacak
ve merakı daha da arttı.
Şimdi mağaranın yüksekteki girişinden
yansıyan ışığı merak ediyor
ve güç bela mağaradan yukarıya doğru
tırmanmak için kolları sıvadı,
bu yolculuğu göze aldı
ve aklında sorular var.
Haklı sorular.
Mesela "Bu kuklalar da acaba
başka bir şeyin gerçekliği mi?"
veya "Mağaranın dışı var mı?"
"Mağaranın dışı tehlikeli bir yer mi
yoksa güvenli bir yer mi?"
Aradığı cevaplar acaba
mağaranın dışında mı
ve güç bela kendini dışarıya doğru atıyor
ama mağaranın dışı çok
aydınlık, fazla aydınlık.
Karanlığa alışmış gözleri
kör edecek kadar aydınlık.
O yüzden çıktığında
ilk etapta yere bakıyor.
Yerdeki şeyleri anlamaya çalışıyor,
yeryüzüyle bir ilişki kuruyor
ve gözleri gün ışığına alıştığı zaman
yavaş yavaş bakışını
yukarıya doğru kaldırıyor
ve tüm canlılığın kaynağı
olan güneşi görüyor.
Şimdi artık bütün anlamları,
bütün tanımları yeniden yapacak.
Hayatı ve kendini yeniden
anlamlandıracak
ve burası güzel bir yer,
burada güneş var sıcacık.
Hafif bir rüzgar esiyor, bulutlar güzel,
ağacın renkleri güzelmiş
ve burada rahat
ama burada kalabilecek mi?
Yolcuğun sonu burası mı?
Bu bir mutlu son mu?
Hayır, hikâye devam ediyor.
Bundan sonra Platon
öyle inanılmaz bir adım atıyor ki
bütün gayretiyle, çabasıyla,
merakıyla, dirayetiyle
mağaradan kendini dışarı atmış olan kişiyi
gerisin geri mağaraya gönderiyor
çünkü bu kişinin asıl sınavı
şimdi başlayacak.
Gördüğü gerçeklikle,
yaptığı yeni tanımlamalarla
yeni anlamlandırmalarla,
acaba hayatı şimdi nasıl yaşayacak
ve kilit soru şu:
Hâlâ soruyu ve cevabı
canlı tutabilecek mi?
Hâlâ zamanı geldiğinde cevapları
bırakabilme cesaretini gösterebilecek mi?
Bu zorlu yolculuğu, mağaranın dışına
doğru olan zorlu yolculuğu,
meşakkatli yolculuğu
tekrar göze alabilecek mi?
Yoksa mağaranın karanlığında kalıp
o rahat rutine uyup, verili cevaplarla,
başkasının kontrol ettiği bir
gerçeklikte kalmayı mı tercih edecek?
Yani bile isteye zincirleri
kendine mi takacak?
"Ben kimim?"
"Hayatımın anlamı ne?"
"Vücuda getirmek istediğim
değerler neler?"
"Beni mutlu eden şeyler neler?"
İşte bu sorulara hazır
cevaplar bulduğumuzda,
soruları kapatırız
ve kendimizi zincirlere vururuz.
Ruhumuzu sıkıştırırız.
O yüzden bu soruları açık tutmak,
canlı tutmak,
bizi mağaranın dışına taşıyacak
olan yolculuğun imkânıdır
ve bu yolculuk kolay değil.
Bu yolculuk zor.
İnsan olmanın çelişkilerini
ve belirsizliği de beraberinde getiriyor
ama ancak bu yolculuk sayesinde
belirsizliğin o özgürleştirici
alanını fark ediyoruz.
Soruyu açık tutmanın
cesaretini gösterebiliyoruz
çünkü ancak o belirsizlik alanında,
bütün cevaplar geriye çekildiğinde
kendi sorumuzu yakalayabiliyoruz
ve bu yolculukta merakı hep canlı
tutmak için bize yardımcı olacak
en güzel yol arkadaşı
da felsefedir.
Şimdi tekrar soralım:
Felsefe ne işe yarar?
Beni dinlediğiniz için
ve çizimleriyle bana destek olduğu için
Gizem Karayavuz'a çok teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)